- I bite my nails like a ninja.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
("Wind Bend" by D Press)
- (inaudible) is here.
- [Gary] Okay.
- He's around the corner.
Once they're set and ready to
go we're just gonna pick up with
you in your office again.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Evan] And
then we'll walk over.
- [Gary] This video
you guys made for me?
Which is really good.
One of the
biggest business debates,
one of the biggest
debates in business,
answer it in 90 seconds.
But Instagram
videos are only 60 seconds.
Cool, I'd post it anyway.
(group laughter)
Want to see what
people are gonna say.
- [Andy] Talking
about translations in China.
- [Gary] Well then we can just
go with a pure content strategy
which is like post the shit.
- [Andy] Just post it.
Okay.
- [Other Tyler] And
see what happens there.
- [Gary] I do think
it's worth the upside.
- [Andy] 100%.
So I'm just gonna
get rolling with it.
- Okay.
- [Andy] Cool.
- Should I take
Mandarin night classes?
(group laughter)
I have so much time.
How's the episode
gonna be from yesterday?
- [Other Tyler] Good.
- Some good stuff?
- [Evan] Guys
playing, card's set.
Desks over here.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Evan] You're gonna pop over,
do as much as we
can with him there.
They do want to share
with you the deck itself.
- [Gary] Good.
Let's do that. Okay.
- [Evan] And
then do that in here.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Evan] Apple TV, super simple.
- Walk in (censored) and be like
we're the three fuckers that are
gonna get it to a (censored).
And like why don't we
make America give a fuck about
getting to a
(censored) impressions?
Why don't we like, so one of the
things I think has always worked
for me is 'cause maybe
TV's doing it right now.
I love breaking the third wall.
- [Steve] Mhmmm.
- Like that's when it gets real.
Honestly, I got another idea.
Idea number two and
this is fucking big.
(Lisa laughs)
I'm telling you it's big, Lis.
(group laughter)
Guys, it's really big though.
- [DRock] Uh oh, he stood up.
- Yep, you know this.
Honestly, this is
the one I want to do.
Oh fuck, I'm so into this.
You ready?
I think (censored) should come
out with a campaign that says
fuck (censored)
we're never (censored).
- [Man] Yeah.
- Straight up.
That's the campaign.
(group laughter)
("Long Walk" D Press)
- [Tyler] Did you
see by the way,
there's an
email in your inbox...
- [Gary] Get me
the Office of the CEO.
It's an interesting time.
We need to be conscious.
I'm here for
you guys on this, okay?
One thing historically that we
did not do that I am fully on
board with is I want to fight.
Let them say no.
- [Claude] Really?
- Let them change their mind.
I want to make these calls of
I really want to be
involved in this year.
This is my dirt year.
I want to be involved.
Real quick, I'm very comfortable
with you guys discussing this.
Whoever wants to take it,
I think I want to
play the John Madden role.
I want to do color commentary.
I think it's important for
somebody that's so bought into
me to realize how
special this organization is
above and beyond me.
Here's my punchline, if we
believe in something enough,
we'll build the
internal capability.
- [Man 2] Yep.
- [Man 3] Yep.
- Cool.
I was in a meeting with the
team getting prepared for this
opportunity and Eric was
updating me on the conversation
he had with you and I just
wanted clarity for myself and
for you so that we
can get to the best place.
When we're talking about
breakthrough work and things of
that nature, you know, obviously
I communicated this when we were
together but I wanted to just
hear it from you on this one.
Obviously, my full belief is
that the breakthrough work comes
from the cadence and the
strategy of Facebook Video
against those segmentations
moreso than the creative idea.
Of course the
creative is the variable.
But I want to walk in there with
five to six different
videos per market.
So, the net cost of
one video for Europe,
U.K., Germany
things of that nature.
It's my belief and the way to
actually change your business
from a negative slide I believe
is to take the money that is
normally allocated to a TVC and
to do that in a
Facebook video environment.
And then having contextual
creative per those markets.
You are 100% right and even
worse I always believe that.
What I didn't know until maybe
three years ago was oh shit,
the agency partners aren't
incentivized in
figuring these problems out.
They're just
trying to maximize profit.
That's to me,
I think every company
should not have agencies
and do marketing internally
so that interests are aligned
because I genuinely
agree with what you just said.
It's down to the people and if
the people that are sitting on
the other side of you are
also publicly held companies and
aren't incentivized and putting
in the hours or the work to
guess, to spec, to innovate but
they just want to keep selling
you the model that
makes their margin,
you're never
gonna get to the work.
Can I pee?
- [Tyler] You can pee.
The cameras aren't ready.
- This is what
my life has come to.
I have to ask Tyler if
I'm allowed to fuckin' pee.
Time to edit. DailyVee.
DRock films,
Tyler edits,
I'm the star.
So this is one of my least
favorite things to do in my life
right now which
is review DailyVee.
I never historically
over the last decade
watched any of my own content.
But there's so much.
I already had to edit two or
three things out that would have
been out of context that could
have exposed a client issue.
I hate this.
But I love 'cause
I see Other Tyler.
Actually, you know what?
I think we should cut that.
- [DRock] Yeah?
- Yeah. I do.
100% of my day
is based on romance.
Ends with Ryan, right here.
Ends at 18:25, okay?
Guys, I'm a
master at Premiere Pro.
(DRock and
Other Tyler laugh)
You know?
- [Other Tyler] Title?
- [Gary] What'd I say with Dunk?
What's the funny
thing I did with Dunk?
Quick reactions?
- Oh and then you said
like, "I'm the strongest ever"
or something like that.
- [Gary] I like
the quick reactions.
Let's run with that.
- Okay.
- They care about
shit like the chair.
We're like divulging secrets.
Hollywoooood.
That one hair on
your forehead. (laughs)
Listen, you guys are
coming from the right place.
I love it.
Of course you can.
You know like
100th of a fucking inch, right?
- [Man 4] There we go.
- [Man 5] That's the ticket.
- [Gary] The magic.
That's how we do it.
The chair.